well here we are we've arrived and we're
waiting a bit
drop on our road again doing what we do
that's sounds like the whole rest of the
Fleetwood downtown Chatham we're just
thinking close to home now
plenty of up yet
you know we haven't been getting the
biggest fish by any means you can't pick
the sides and fist and fights the hook
the trick is catching fish
the big one will come eventually
we started using this stand-up ride last
year and it's been pretty lucky for us
it's a bit different than fighting a
bluefin with a stationary rods but
because it's not connected to the boat
while we're hooked up we have a lot more
control during the fight I'm just gonna
throw it in the water it's using much
lighter weight line so when we do hook
up we have to be much more careful that
we don't lose it well I drove the boat
here
and the boys slept they got rested up
now we're gonna switch I'm going to
leave it up to the boys to catch your
fish which I know they can do just fine
and I'm gonna go lay down and hopefully
they'll get me up screaming with a fish
on
all right good luck guys
did you take out our life heron
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
up up there he is
dig it out we got a tuner on here
on a stand up
holding the rod the whole time
[Music]
those other guys took the big long ride
we decided to fish local
and fish the light gear and so far it's
working out good a plan is coming
together you know you don't have to go
100 miles to catch a tuna fish you just
need confidence in fishing in your own
backyard and picking your own Tomatoes
just that we'd hope guys get in a pipe
while I was laying down
now all we gotta do is get him in the
boat
we definitely know it's a tuna but we're
not too sure on size just yet
gonna get a little closer to be sure
it's another good keeper
hopefully it is
yeah it's definitely a challenge finding
it this way you really feel it
in your legs with this harness but you
do get to control the pitch a little bit
better I feel
definitely pretty cool all the West
Coast guys do it over in California this
way so fighting a bluefin on the East
Coast like this
pretty cool if we can land them I see
them down there
that's a keeper it's a keeper
definitely keeper okay back up to him
he's turning he's turning
his heads towards me that's right you
just focus on you Jay I get this
good job Joe
how do you like me now
coming over with the Gale Gaff all right
my left side right now
hang on
yeah it's a big one
[Music]
job guys
stuck with a plan stuck with the plan
good job well done well done boys
[Music]